ladies and gents
how many abortions
is too many abortions
wow
anyone anyone could start let me go
around you start actually like I'm
interested
how many too many you just you have a
look on your face I'm like I just want
to see what you got to say uh I suppose
one is probably too many abortions
okay
yeah I think I think having any is is
too many to be honest
um
I think there's a mathematical equation
yeah it's a
I don't think it's weird to say these
things because it's like I don't think
there's a number I can give you but
there's a lot of things I can take into
account with these things like if you're
in a long-term relationship with a
person and for whatever reason whatever
things happen I can give you one per
long-term relationship uh-huh
if she's no obviously not 20 but if
you're like 40 you've been in two 10
year long relationships and for whatever
reason you had to have an abortion
before if you've been in 340 you should
have kids with all due respect yeah of
course but I'm saying it's a
circumstance that's why I'm giving it
like a mathematical equation for
relationship time kind of relationship
all that kind of stuff because you never
know what people's life stories are at
the end of the day isn't it is it worse
to abort a kid when you're in a
relationship because you know that you
know that person's stable of course so
so why do they get a pass almost but you
don't know that person stable sometimes
that's what that's why it has to be a
mathematical equation with a lot of a
lot of intake there's no number I can
give you I have to give you a e equals m
c squared
so I just okay so so I'm 25. how many
abortions is too many abortions for a 25
year old anywhere more than one is crazy
okay so a 30 a 30 year old is it two 35
three yeah 44. if you're 35 and been in
two six or more year relationship I can
give you too but why have you been on
long term because you never wait I've
got a question for you there
is your answer based on personal
anecdote and I'm not saying you
personally but someone that you have
like hold close yeah it's been in a
situation yeah and therefore yeah your
rule is based on yes I agree with that
100 because because I've seen some of
the other side of like oh okay cool I
had this preconceived conception of like
abortions and then when you see someone
like literally
have no obviously I don't want to be
like those families who come in here
it's not what I'm saying it's not what
I'm saying this is what I'm saying it's
a case-by-case basis with a better
equations and there's so many things you
have to take into account but if you're
just an average person who's just live
an average life and you're 20 something
years old you shouldn't really have more
than one unless your situations will die
every [ __ ] really when I when I know
people that have had abortions I just
think they're stupid
why is that why is that how did you get
pregnant
yeah you bypassed all of them yeah every
single one yeah so sometimes you meet
those people who literally are falling
because I don't want to end people's
business out but like you're in a
beautiful relationship with this guy you
had to do it on the download because he
didn't know you're pregnant because if
he knows you're pregnant
on you because he's already abusive
again I don't want to sound like these
was she was she hit was she hitting back
no of course not you sure very sure most
most the most abusive relationships most
abusive again I agree if you want to
understand that but this the again is
this goes back to us I said again like a
million like a personal but yeah it goes
back to probably with personal anecdotes
I have stories of situations where if I
was to see that situation again I could
at least give some sort of
but it has to be a day pass it can't be
a thing where this is like a regular
occurrence
okay what about you
um I think after one
is too many
and even and even with that is
questionable because if you're laying
down unprotected you know there's a
chance you can fall pregnant yeah
you know what I mean so even that's
questionable but then again like you
said with your whole mathematical
equation whatever I teach maths but I
don't know where you got your
mathematical equation from I've got two
Asian GCSE
[Laughter]
but yeah
um yeah I think after one
let's say you have this out of a
of this world excuse and you got
pregnant you didn't know you got
pregnant you're not ready okay that's
fine now that's one second time you're
pushing it um
there's abstinence ever
sorry yeah abstinence yeah I'm sorry
yeah yeah just two yeah I was just gonna
say this abstinence not ever fall into
this equation because for me I I waited
me and my husband we waited until
marriage I feel like
if if you don't want to have children of
course then you you need to understand
what you're doing waiting to have sex
until marriage yes how long are you with
him
um we got together
we got married
um last year so we were together for
about nine months oh wow nine months
yeah so we both waited until marriage
okay and so I think when you look at it
from that scenario you kind of have to
think okay how how how do you how do you
want to see the outcome of your life
ultimately if I don't want to have
children and I want to wait to ensure
that I'm doing it in the safest space
which is in a family your religious unit
I am religious yeah well I'm Christian
so yeah that's so cute you guys waited
that's so rare nowadays especially it's
rare for guys I